the Joe Rogan experience you know i-i've
been in here in jumps and spurts right
and those jumps and spurts you have
become like the most powerful [ __ ]
broadcaster on the planet like crazy
popular everywhere then you can crack a
smile you know I'm writing [ __ ] well
it's dull it's only hard no it's weird
why cuz it's well don't you enjoy it
come on [ __ ] I wanted to like my
whole life I wanted to be at the top of
something real you are at it I was the
top of podcast for like a minute back
when we started and should pack in the
old fleshlight days but like you are now
beyond you've transcended the [ __ ]
medium you got to tell me it don't wince
you got to tell me
it feels good otherwise what am i
striving for in my career and to be
honest I don't really strive if you've
seen the [ __ ] I do but like there is an
idea of like you know oh man at the top
it must be amazing and like no [ __ ]
you're absolutely the top you have
[ __ ] Snowden on your podcast dude
everything feels exactly the same but
different explain um it's still fun I
still enjoy talking to people like you
and I had my friend Kyle kolinsky on
earlier I've had some really interesting
people on I love
I've always enjoyed talking to
interesting people so that's the same
everything's the same in that regard
it's different in that it's it's very
obvious when I go places that it's
having more of an impact because you're
the same person right but the world
changes like the impact you put out the
signal and the world sort of changes in
shares more lovers more haters more this
more that just it's everything just
increases yeah more yeah it becomes more
it becomes it becomes weird people want
to interview you people want to do
things and I don't do any of those
things
let me tell can tell quick yeah because
I don't I'd never want to cut you off
because I could listen to you you're
just a shame in your guru I love coming
here and I have love to come in here but
now there's this different onus to it
because it's like I better use my time
wisely [ __ ] Bernie Sanders is next
you know what I'm saying like this it's
it's it's nice but this is how authentic
Rogan is so we're making Jay and Silent
Bob reboot and I reach out to like
everybody I know about being in the
movie and you know even the people that
are like oh man I'm gonna go to New
Orleans that's far I'm like you do
remember I almost died of a [ __ ]
heart attack like all right I'm coming i
guilted like everybody into coming so
Jordan who's our producer Jason Mewes
his wife she runs our company she's like
I I reached out to Joe manager and he
said he's not interested I was like you
know what let me handle this like I'll
reach out to Joe I got Joe on Direct I
don't need a manager man some 10% or
[ __ ] get in between me and my boy and
[ __ ] so I can email their text to Joe
and I was like hey man we're making
reboot do you want to come play and just
flat out on Front Street as true as you
can be he goes I hate that acting [ __ ]
and you were like I'm flattered but I
don't want to do that he's like I'll
talk to you about it when it's tough I
was like all right that's how authentic
you are that's you know you're in a
place right now where you're like can't
[ __ ] ruin my credibility with [ __ ]
like no it's not a ruin the credibility
what is it I don't like doing it and it
takes too much time I don't have a mess
that is not and that was not me going
look what I thought it was a fantastic
how those adorable on it I was like
trying to sew on France yeah why tell me
why cuz I do too much I'm doing you know
between all the podcasts that I do doing
commentary for the UFC doing stand-up
comedy there's a lot of things three
things you've been doing for the last
[ __ ] day bro there's a lot of things
I mean they've all increased perhaps
like I don't I'm not in the fighting
world so I don't know if your your jobs
there have exponentially increased I
knew you were no actually cut that back
a lot and the more I've cut that back
the more cut things back to happier I am
and then stand-up has that Danny's not
cut back at all so this is increased
this has increased quite a bit yeah so
the idea I'm doing six podcast this week
and then I'm flying to New York on
Thursday and then I'm doing Artie Lange
on Friday in New York's that would be a
seventh podcast we're gonna carry that
one over to the next week right but
assist that does not leave any room for
trips to New Orleans to do a movie
though doesn't leave any room to do
anything this
I get all these weird requests to do
things that just are not interesting I
don't want I don't want to do them and
yours is one of the most interesting I
know I believe me I'm not voting on the
spot going like why didn't you come I
just don't have time it was the most on
brand [ __ ] response and it was also a
lesson and like let me let me reach out
this manager knows nothing in the
manager
exactly my manager is a rare thing she
knows exactly how I feel about
everything so he doesn't you know I just
I say no to everything man
[Applause]